um so i have a few questions i like
throwing some curveballs before we talk
about south of heaven um if you could
get the financing to make anything you
wanted what would you make and why
i would like to make my dream
the incredible shrinking man
the reason i want to do it is because
it's one of the greatest i think i think
sci-fi film ever made
but i think that with today's uh you
know technology
there's a way of making it of a
more like a survivalist
thriller
so i would do it ways of revenant
like a revenant
version of the incredible shrinking man
and that's my dream project like if i
like if i had all the money in the world
i'll probably do the incredible
shrinking man
and do something very
bizarre violent but still keep that
beautiful heartbreaking ending
uh that would be an interesting take on
the material um
yeah i wonder
i'm wondering who would finance that
because it would be a expensive movie
with vfx
yeah
i'm just making a fight with a cat
that is more like fight with the bear in
revenant
if you know what i mean
no 100 percent um so a number of years
ago you worked on obviously big bad
wolves um a number of number of years
ago quentin tarantino called it the best
film of 2013.
what was your reaction when you heard he
said that
it wasn't like i was amazed because you
know he was one of my he still is one of
my idols uh
with the cohen brothers of course um
and i think i was surprised very
surprised i you know i'm coming from
very humble
home
i'm just you know i was a film critic
and a film scholar i never thought of
making films
um
and then suddenly you know i i work with
my student back then he lured me into
making films with him that's novot and
and then you know suddenly he's putting
a projector light on you so that was
amazing
um
but you know for me i just i'm the kind
of guy who just says okay he gave me my
projector he said these beautiful things
he says and i want to you know evolve
and develop in my own uh you know
wherever i need to go so it was amazing
he opened doors for us you just you know
you're not you never expected things
like that it was beautiful thing for him
to do and he's still a supporter so it's
great
um so you premiered south of heaven in
the beyond fest um what did it what did
it mean to you to you know to premiere
it there
it was you know it was
for me beyond fast represents uh the
kind of you know audience that i'm
looking for because you know you
probably saw self of evan it's a basket
case kind of movie it starts dramatic it
goes into a whole
darker place and and so for me i always
i know there's
an audience for it and usually those
audiences are you could find them in
genre film festival so beyonce is one of
the my favorite festivals i was there
only as a you know as audience up until
and they wanted big bad wolves to
premiere their not premiere but be there
in 2014 and it didn't happen so um
when every man these fellas says come
over to beyond fest and screen this
movie with us i just say well that's
going to be the best crowd in the world
and you know it went like
it went amazing theirs because
they really uh
they're fine with everything crazy that
happens in a movie
of this sort and that's the kind of
audience i'm looking for you know that's
the kind of actors that respond into the
script
and that's the kind of audience i need
you know because it's all you know it's
crazy
yeah it definitely we're going to get
into that it definitely is a mixture of
uh genres because it well actually we
can just talk about it but like it's
funny at times it's dark at times it's
heartbreaking at times it mixes a whole
bunch of different things together um
i guess could you um what was that
appeal to you to sort of mix every like
you know what i mean like it's not just
one thing
it's just the way i'm you know i'm wired
uh i just cannot think of a one-tone
kind of script it happened to me with
rabies and big bad wolves and now in
this one i just
uh i guess because i'm a little bit i'm
not bipolar but i think my my persona
has this ups and downs and [ __ ] i'm i'm
i'm very funny at real life but i'm very
i'm a very sad clown in real life too so
i think for me it was like almost
natural to be
jumping around from one end to another
but the way i write is that i want to
give the audience the best
uh roller coaster emotional roller
coaster they could have in a film
because when i watch today's movies
you know i like a lot of movies i'm a
cinephile
but what i see is that you know there's
one usually one tone to two tones and
you usually you could you know guess the
entire movie from minute five to minute
120. so as a writer and a filmmaker i
just want to make you know something
that will not feel that way that will
not feel derivative that will not feel
that you've seen this movie so many
times so usually what i try to do and i
did it in both my first movies is give
you a little bit of something that you
you're sure you watch like
in rabies it's it's the slasher in the
woods and big bad wolf is the cop who
investigate a crime
and he thinks he has the right suspect
and in this one it's the guy who goes
out of prison to reunite with his you
know loved one and then he has that
parole officer who gives him trouble and
you think that's the movie i made right
so that's how i write like i have like
those 25 to 30 minutes which i play with
your expectations to think oh well i've
seen this movie i like these movies if
it's this movie then fine
and then i i like to you know steer away
from whatever you expected and just find
ways to entice the audience entice you
know the spectator and and give him a
lot you know a lot of emotions and
as many emotions he could have in you
know in one movie
i really like your opening shot with
it's just on jason
and it's him talking to someone off
camera and he has to show a lot of
emotion um can you sort of talk about
how you came up with that's the way you
wanted to open the movie with him
talking like that
yeah
that was one of my first decisions is uh
i wanted people to
get a hold of jason sudeikis and jimmy
ray the character like i wanted him to
to judge him instead of the parole
committee because i felt that if i'll do
like a simple shot reverse shot that
will be a little bit you know simplistic
and we've seen it in so many movies and
you kind of judged jimmy through the
eyes of the parole committee so what i
thought of
is that i want to yank the
the spectator into the point of view of
the parole committee so they
have to listen to jimmy's long story
about you know his 12 years without any
and i and by the end of those three
minutes if if he managed to steal your
heart you're gonna stay with him for the
duration of the movie and i also feel
that as a filmmaker a director when you
work with actors i like to give them
space it's something i couldn't do a lot
in big bad wolves and rabies although
there are long shots long takes also in
those movies but in this one i wanted to
give them like space
so the film will have a more authentic
honest real
emotions and i think that the long take
and putting a camera on an actor and let
him deliver uh a performance will make
him even better because you know the
fragility you see in jason sudeikis and
the honesty and he you know he's
mumbling sometimes he's like uncertain
that there's awkwardness in the
beginning and i think it it feels real
because it's also real when he when you
act that way because you're afraid
you're gonna mess that one take right
your your and then we need to cut it and
do it again so all those butterflies you
could catch them
you could catch them while you shooting
it that way
uh you have a great cast in this uh i'm
just curious what how did you i was
gonna make a joke but talk about putting
together the the the actors you have in
this because you really did put together
a great cast
yes
thank you thank you again like i said i
was shocked because uh i was i was not
prepared like it's a it's a three
million dollar movie uh 25 days of shoot
you you don't ex and i'm from israel and
i have no you know my name is not that
big in the u.s so i had no idea uh i
could even get these actors but luckily
i had you know jason was looking at the
same time for it was before ted lasso uh
great timing by me uh
he was looking to do something else i
think he was looking to do something not
not just dark but you know broaden his
horizon and show that he has like those
incredible dramatic chops that he truly
has
and i was looking for a comedian because
i like to write i like to go against
type when i direct movies i don't like i
don't like to put you know whatever you
expect of jimmy ray to be because when
you start
uh casting a movie like that the the
first name you're gonna get is those
action movie stars that you see in so
many movies but i knew i needed somebody
that
his eyes are like these big puppy eyes
and that you're is a down to earth kind
of guy and you just want to hug him from
the get-go
and then i saw colossal with uh with
sudeikis and you know and hathaway and i
knew he has that brooding menacing uh
crazy eyes when he wants to go dark and
i said that would be amazing if i could
have jason do all the crazy stuff my
script needs him to do
but still the the audience will feel a
deep emotions toward him and empathy
because it's jason's today kiss and now
i think it's even harder for the viewer
to see stuff of evan probably because
there's ted lasto in in you know so it's
even more heartbreaking and more crazy
than just seeing jason sudeiki's before
ted lasso as for the rest evangeline
again was looking for something like
this she's you know she's been in marvel
movies she's been in the hobbit but she
was looking to do something that will
break the because she says that she
always get cast in the warrior princess
kind of roles she is always like
this you know tough cookie and she
wanted a movie
that will make that will allow her to
show more and more sides of her i'm like
she's glowing she's fragile she's she
could she could go dark she could be
feisty she could be fierce against price
when she needed to be in the movie and
she you know and have these great uh
emotions with their co-star and when
they met it was like you know
fireworks and i and and what you see on
screen is what what happened on set they
were like you know they look amazing
together uh coulter
i always again go against typecast so
price on the page is like you know uh a
villain right but it could be like if
you if you gave it to like an overactor
that will be like the worst corny hokey
character in the world but when you gave
it to michael terre he has this the
ability to tone down and everything
he could take a line that could be like
over the top but he said he's delivering
it so elegantly and that's what i was
looking for an actor that could take
something that on pages like could be
over the top cheesy uh villain guy
and then he will put it into his
elegance you know delivery
and also i wanted somebody that could
match jason sudeikis when you see them
both on on screen because it was
important to me to build a villain that
will become sort of a protagonist almost
or or the victim
later on in the movie
and then you know shay wiggum came along
and
you know he's amazing i think he's the
best supporting actor working
character actor is not only supporting
these days but he's the best character
actor i think the us has to offer right
now he reminds me a lot of the actors
from the 70s and
uh those kind of people that came and
just steal the show with one scene
and you know i call him 50 shades of
shay because he could
he gives you like 50 interpretation to
every line in your movie and you know
because he wants to nail it he wants to
be in the precise place where it's not
caricature where it's not like cheesy or
hokey and it's more realistic even
though he's doing like crazy uh
over-the-top kind of things in the movie
and jeremy bob was you know
surprised to like getting him to do the
honest frank was a blessing um i really
didn't expect getting all these great
actors really
yeah well there's no way you you could i
mean it's just it's it uh it's really
hard to do so uh one other thing i
really like your shot in the third in
the third act i don't want to do any
spoilers but it involves um
a house and jason having to go you know
do some stuff in the house i'm just
can you talk about uh filming that
sequence because there's a lot going on
yeah well
i won't spoil it but i do i will say
that i was looking for a way to do the
anti uh john wick kind of uh action
scene
so it won't be like you're rooting or
you know dancing and clapping your hands
for a violent scene
so what i i plan with my dp matt
mitchell he is a shot that will make it
feel more of like a horror movie
uh like a home invasion movie so when
you you know protagonist does what he
does at the third act you will be
surprised of the way it's built like and
where you are
uh
in place for you know you look i wanted
you to feel as a spectator
as a judge and not somebody who takes
like
he's you know he's not walking with
jason sudeikis he's ju he's walking
outside his perspective and and can
judge from the side what's going on and
not really be with him so when we
thought about it we saw a lot of brian
the palmer films and also takashi
kitano's sonatin and i i wanted that
shot to be something that you're
sometimes with the protagonist sometimes
you lose them sometimes you go with the
henchmen sometimes you get back to him
and then you lose him again so you're
never really
with him
and it's very chaotic so on the day
we have only 25 days of shoot so i
couldn't do it like forever i had one
day to get this shot right and we didn't
want to use cgi because i'm a real i'm a
true believer in practical effects and
getting whatever you can on set
so
so uh
we did in one day you do half a day of
rehearsal
and then you have like uh limited amount
of text that you could do without you
know needing another day so we had like
seven takes
and that's it
so take one you know the script doesn't
work take two the muzzle flash doesn't
work take three it's all good but the
ones
the one guy doesn't fall right so it was
like
after six stakes we're like oh my god
and they came to me and this aaron just
can you [ __ ] it like you can you
just cut it into
whatever
you know i don't know because this needs
to feel like a true home invasion this
needs to feel like you're living in in
the moment because jason is living in
the moment and i wanted that and you get
surprised from all angles so we did a
seventh shot
and that's the shot that entered the
movie and uh
it was amazing it was the best night i
think you never i never seen jason
sudeiki he's so happy and so pumped like
the day he with that sequence he was
like
dancing and you know celebrating as if
we just you know
got on the everest
sure uh um
i love talking about editing because
that's ultimately where the movie comes
together uh what did you learn when you
got in the editing room about the movie
that perhaps you weren't expecting and
did you make any uh adjustments based on
like feedback from people you trust
what i learned is uh
that there i always believe in that that
you write a script and then you write
the script again in uh pre-production
and then you write a script in
post-production and then you write you
write it forever right so i i i always
learn in the editing room that you could
that you could find out that you made a
totally different film than the one that
was on page and with this movie what i
got is
um
the
[Music]
love story needed more air than i then
it's in then what the what i you know
what i had on page i knew like when i
saw the movie i knew i cannot just
shortcut
all the things that you know you usually
do like you delete while editing a movie
like aaron there's too much love here
can you take you know of like 10 minutes
of the love story and let's go straight
to the action
so
that's what i found out while editing
south of evan that whenever
uh you try to uh
short
make a shortcut it didn't work uh i did
find out that sometimes you need to drop
a scene that doesn't you know
elevate the movie or give you what you
need
and and that's it and i also learned
that you need to sometimes uh play with
the rhythm
more than you thought
because the script was like so
well constructed
but then you feel that okay i need some
more time in the first act so people
will need will
believe the you know the twists and
turns better in the second and third
acts that was the most important thing
for me to do is that i needed people to
believe what's going to happen in third
second and third act so i needed to
build a very strong opening
so once everything starts to you know
develop very fast
they would believe everything that
happens
yeah i also think that like i really
like that scene of uh jason in the
bathroom getting ready to come out
after he got out of jail and they're
both just sitting there nervous and
trying to figure out if it's a you know
if you for example if you shorten that
then you don't care about them you know
these are those scenes that pull you in
to make you care
yeah and that's that's like uh something
that evangeline asked me to do because
i'll i'll be very modest about you know
the screenplay
the scene was like not as good the scene
was like one of those cliche moments
where
uh you know jason is in the bathtub and
then he pulls her into the bathtub and
then drinking beer together and it was
like so cheesy and when i i sent him
angeline to watch to get away by sam
peckinpah and she came back to me and
see she said in sam pakenpa's getaway
there is such a lovely honest moment
when he comes out of jail and they have
that timid moment in the you know when
they're living in their bedroom can you
do something can you write something
like that for us
and i immediately went to rewrite that
scene with all everything that you saw
like him by the scales watching his
tummy her you know judging yourself by
the you know by the mirror and that's
that's the best surprise and best
collaboration that you could have with
actors that come they know their arc
better than you because they're
concentrate concentrating on their part
in the movie so they come to you and
they say i i think you could do a more
honest job as a writer here how about
showing the timidness of that kind of
moment and i just you know sped into my
writing room and i rewrote everything
and that's the scene you saw
yeah it it's uh she gave you very good
advice
she's the best she's truly the
right um so i'm basically um uh
uh i am curious what you have coming up
after this are you writing anything are
you working on anything
i'm you know i'm reading and i'm
working on a couple of ideas i have an
idea for like uh pyrokinesis uh kind of
story um
with a girl that you know teenager and
then a woman i have an idea for a
ghost haunted hotel but it's more like
diabolique
uh so yeah i'm i'm writing i'm just
waiting to finish the launch of uh south
of heaven here so i could go back and
you know be in that head space again but
yeah i'm
i'm waiting to deconstruct more genres
for you know the american audience
no listen um i'm going to say congrats
on the movie for real and i hope it
opens a lot more doors for you as a
filmmaker um and i just want to thank
you for giving me your time
of course stephen thank you for having
me
you